only a dozen kilometers from the eu's
eastern border
the Russian army is committing barbaric
actions during its invasion of Ukraine
it is bombing and launching missiles
killing innocent people
at the same time
the entire world is witnessing the
determined and brave resistance by the
Ukrainian Army and population
as Russian forces unleash their assault
on Kiev and other Ukrainian cities
we are resolved to continue imposing
massive costs on Russia
costs that will further isolate Russia
from the International Financial system
and our economies
in coordination with President Biden
president
Schultz and prime minister draghi as
well as prime minister Trudeau and prime
minister Johnson
we considered a significant tightening
of our International response
the European Union and its partners are
working to [ __ ] pujin's ability to
finance his War Machine
I will now propose to EU leaders the
following measures first
we commit to ensuring that a certain
number of Russian banks are removed from
Swift
this will ensure that these banks are
disconnected from the International
Financial system
and harm the ability to operate globally
Swift is the world's dominant global
interbank payment system
cutting Banks off
will stop them from conducting most of
their financial transactions worldwide
and effectively block Russian exports
and imports
second
we will stop putting from using his War
chest
we will paralyze the assets of Russia's
Central Bank
this will freeze its transactions
and it made it impossible for the
central bank to liquidate assets
and finally
we will work to prohibit Russian
oligarchs
from using their financial assets on our
markets
all of these measures
will significantly harm Putin's ability
to finance his work
and they will have an eroding severely
eroding impact on his economy
Putin embarked on a path aiming to
destroy Ukraine
but what he's also doing in fact is
destroying the future of his own country